in the opening scene we are narrated
that during the hibor age a group of
sorcerers from the dark Empire of acaron
created a mask from the skulls of dead
Kings through a dark ritual they
sacrificed their pure-blooded daughters
to bestow the mask with the power to
dominate the entire world with that
Newfound power acaron embarked on their
mission taking down the other kingdoms
one after another at one point they
launched their attack on the only
remaining tribe The Barbarians from
simaria after a very violent and bloody
battle The Barbarians defeated the
sorcerers and destroyed the mystical
mask in the aftermath the pieces of the
Mask were scattered across the
widespread kingdoms and hidden to
prevent any man from ever wielding such
power again however a prophecy foretells
that someone would try to put all the
pieces together again the scene then
fast forwards to several years later
showing an ongoing war between the
samarians and their rival clan in the
middle of the battle the Barbarian
Chieftain corin's pregnant wife is
fatally injured in her final breath she
asks Corin to cut open her stomach so
that she can see their baby before she
dies that's metal Corin fulfills her
final wish and she names the baby Conan
before succumbing to her injuries years
pass by and Conan grows up to become a
fierce teenager despite his early age he
is so eager for battle that he competes
with adult men in the tribe one morning
all the teens from the tribe take a test
to prove themselves as potential
Warriors Corin also allows his son to
participate in this test following this
they all get ready for a race in which
they will have to make a round of the
forest as soon as it begins the boys
start pushing each other to cut off the
competition not caring if anyone falls
and gets hurt shortly after they're
ambushed by a bunch of Warriors from a
rival Clan upon witnessing this all the
participating teens Retreat back to
their place but Conan makes a brave
decision to confront them and prove
himself as a
Warrior come at me as he steps forward
the rival gang surrounds him and intends
to kill him however Conan fights back
and snatches their weapon to take down
all the enemies one after another after
eliminating everyone he returns home
with severed heads rip them off myself
leaving the tribe people in shock seeing
the Readiness of his son Corin takes the
boy to his Foundry and teaches him how
to make a sword also revealing some
secrets of Steel furthermore Corin
begins training his son in swordsmanship
but Conan being an impatient student
often lets his anger interfere with his
lessons as a result Corin tells him that
he's not ready to have such a sword yet
one day the Barbarian Village is
attacked by armored Warriors led by
kalar Zim he is a warlord seeking to
reunite the mask of Aaron so that he can
revive his dead wife maliva an evil
sorceress and Conquer hiboria seeing
them intruding The Barbarians hastily
Mount their horses to charge at the
enemy in a few moments The Village
becomes a heated Battleground despite
the barbarians best efforts they are
eventually defeated by an overwhelming
number and the cunning tactics of their
foes Corin is brought in front of kalar
who demands the piece of mask that he is
hidden here it's revealed that kalar has
already gathered all the other shards
and he's looking for its final piece
when Corin refuses to disclose any
information he is restrained and
tortured Conan who sees this from his
window jumps in and attacks a warrior
named Lucius cutting his nose off Corin
uses this opportunity to fight back but
both the father and the son are subdued
khar's daughter mik then uses her
special evil power to locate the hidden
Shard now that he has what he wants
kalar chains the father and son to a
cauldron of molten metal hanging right
above them Marik steals corin's Sword
and the village is set Ablaze before the
asants depart Conan puts all of his
efforts into saving his father but Corin
knowing that he can't make it sacrifices
himself to enable his son to escape an
orphaned and grief stricken Conan then
grabs a sword from a pile of bodies and
vows for Revenge following this the
scene fast forwards to 20 years later
Conan who is now a mercenary is working
with a zamorin pirate named Artis one
day the two arrive in the city of mtia
where they raid a slave camp and release
the hostage they then take the hostage
to a beach for a celebration full of
Music women and alcohol amidst the feast
a group of solders shows up and Conan
recognizes their leader as Lucius who is
after a pickpocket Ela Shan in a clever
move to track down his father's Killers
Conan deliberately picks up a fight and
allows himself to be captured alongside
Ela Shan following this the two are
taken to a dirty cell where prisoners
are subjected to labor after waiting for
the right moment Conan single-handedly
attacks all the guards and makes his way
to Lucius he then tortures him until he
finally agrees to talk Lucius reveals
that kalar who has now become a powerful
Shadow Lord is looking for pureblood
descendants of Sorcerers of acaron in
order to awaken the mask's true power he
further discloses that the last
ascendant of that line is currently in
shyur upon retrieving the information
that he needs Conan leaves him at the
mercy of the prisoners announcing that
they're free now in the meantime kalar
and his daughter lead their army to
shyur Monastery where a pureblood
descendant Tamara lives they soon lay
Siege to the town inducing panic among
the residents amidst the chaos an
elderly monk named Fair who knows the
prophecy urges Tamara to escape in a
carriage guarded by some soldiers upon
taking down all of the Town guards kalar
confronts fair and demands for the pure
blood however the monk refuses to
divulge anything which enrages Kar as a
result he smashes his head against the
marble floor resulting in his death maik
then tests the blood of the monastery
girls and realizes that the pure blood
isn't among them simultaneously in the
nearby Forest Conan spots the carriage
and launches his attack mistaking them
for kar's men he swiftly jumps onto the
carries roof and breaks it apart only to
find Tamara surprised he asks about her
identity also demanding kar's
whereabouts but before they can talk
further they're caught up too by kar's
men led by Remo following this Conan
engages in combat with the Enemy
soldiers while Tamara makes her way out
of the running carriage and gets on a
horse when the asent comes closer she
disconnects the carriage and crashes it
into them despite this she is soon
caught by Remo who attacks her horse and
makes her fall to the ground but before
he can take her away Conan intervenes
and starts fighting Remo as well as the
other approaching soldiers after
eliminating all of them Conan discloses
his real identity leaving everyone in
shock Remo tries to escape but Conan
knocks him down as night falls he ties
both Remo and Tamara to prevent their
escape the latter questions why he saved
her if his intention is to capture her
in response Conan explains that he aims
to use her as bait to lure kalar the
following morning Remo wakes up and
explains Tamara's value to Conan he also
offers to lead him to kalar promising a
hefty reward of gold Conan agrees and
ties him to his horse making him guide
him to kalar after a while of traveling
they arrive at his camp where they find
a bunch of abandoned catapults Conan
ties Remo to one of them and covers his
mouth with a message before releasing
the Catapult the villain lands straight
into kar's giant vehicle causing him to
die Marik checks the body and finds the
message where Conan has asked kalar to
meet him at The shyur Outpost alone she
also uses her evil power to figure out
that Tamara is with him in the next
scene kalar and his daughter arrive at
The Outpost where Conan seems to have
set up a trap Tamara pretends to be tied
up to a post but she actually has a
knife in her hand kalar offers him some
money in exchange for Tamara but Conan
Demands a different price his head
hearing this maik uses her magic to
create soldiers out of sand and deploys
them to fight against Conan it's hard
for him to fight these sandmen because
they keep on dodging his Blows By fusing
with the sand despite this he uses his
tactics to overpower the asants one
after another in the interim one of the
sandmen goes to capture Tamara but she
cleverly attacks him with her knife and
starts running away having vanquished
all the sandmen Conan comes face to face
with kalar challenging him to a sword
duel for the first few moments he gives
him a tough fight making it hard for
kalar to defend himself seeing this maik
poisons Conan with a boomerang sword
that weakens him right away this allows
kalar to easily strike him with numerous
powerful blows and gain an upper hand
but before he can deliver a final blow
Tamara drags Conan away and throws a
torch at some spilled oil causing a huge
explosion the duo uses this opportunity
to jump into the sea where they're
rescued by Artis and his crew in the
aftermath Conan talks to Artis sharing
his plan to attack Kar again he also
tells artists to protect Tamara because
she saved his life and she now has his
loyalty later that evening the ship is
attacked by kar's men who try to abduct
Tamara however she lets out a loud
scream that alerts everyone a full-on
Pirate Battle ensues between the two
parties Conan channels his inner rage
unleashing his rage upon the ass salance
while Tamara also manages to stab a few
enemies to death soon after the joint
effort leads them to Victory which makes
them all Overjoyed after some hours of
sailing they reach the coast of kar's
kingdom and Conan sets forth forth on
his vengeful Mission knowing that the
two like each other artist tells Tamara
to meet him one last time to say her
goodbyes he assures her that she can
return by tomorrow morning tomara then
catches up with Conan and the two spend
some private time their conversation
takes a romantic turn and they end up
making love in the nearby cave in the
morning Tamara bids goodbye to the
sleeping Conan and makes her way back to
the ship on her way she's suddenly
ambushed by Marik and her soldiers who
forcefully take her to kar's Kingdom by
the time Conan comes looking for her
they're already gone he now has another
reason to confront kalar in the next
scene Conan travels to ELA Shan's Town
seeking help and breaking into kar's
Fortress Ela Shan is happy to return his
favor and degrees immediately following
this he leads Conan to a secret old mine
Beneath The Fortress he unlocks the door
using his special master key and the two
make their way in upon descending some
stairs they discover that the whole area
is flooded and full of skeletons all of
a sudden a huge tentacle grabs elos Shan
and drags him underwater in a quick
action Conan swims down and stabs the
tentacle before freeing his friend
meanwhile in the Kingdom Tamara is being
prepared for the ritual that would
awaken the mask and give kalara the
power to bring his wife back to life
turns out he intends to use Tamara's
body as a vessel to house the spirit of
his dead wife Maque dresses her with her
mother's wedding attire and and then
ties her to a special Contraption on the
other hand Conan and elos Shan swim out
of the water and find themselves in a
chamber full of caged slaves this
chamber is guarded by a formidable
looking man who is in charge of feeding
a giant multi-tentacled serpent living
underwater spotting The Intruders the
guard alerts others and awakens the
massive creature to have them devoured
in a desperate bid to escape elos Shan
enters a cage but he accidentally locks
himself inside simultaneously Conan
fights the guards while also evading the
tentacles he manages to throw the main
guard into the water causing him to be
ripped apart by the creature Conan then
frees Ela Shan and the duo continues on
their Journey as they ascend The
Fortress they see Tamara being taken to
a Skull Cave where the ritual will be
performed Conan thanks His companion for
the help and continues the rest of the
journey on his own he follows Tamara and
sneaks into the cave silently
dispatching a few guards on his way by
the this point kalara inflicts a wound
on Tamara to get her blood onto the mask
upon applying the blood the mask Springs
to life after which kalar Dawn it he
then resumes the ritual proceeding to
summon his wife's Soul just as the
ritual nears completion Conan launches a
sudden attack on kalar right then the
power of the Mask causes the entire cave
to crumble the contraption holding
tomarrow plummets into the abyss but
fortunately the sticks on the sides make
it get stuck on the walls see seeing
this Conan jumps into the contraption to
save her but kalar also comes behind him
this leads to a sword fight between the
two while standing on the contraption
the commotion results in the contraption
flipping over causing the two fighters
to cling onto its chains seizing this
opportunity Conan reaches toara and
frees her from the restraints she then
runs away while the two men continue
their duel meanwhile Marik follows
Tamara's sent and tracks her down and a
fight initiates between them as well
Tamara struggles against Mar's Superior
strength fueled by evil Powers as a
result she screams for help prompting
Conan to rush towards her maik pins her
down and is on the verge of delivering a
final blow when our hero shows up in a
fit of rage he cuts off her hand and
Tamara pushes her off to her death the
pair then run towards safety but they
are once again confronted by kalar a
final battle ensues between the two of
them this time Conan gains the upper
hand and even reclaims his his father's
sword from the villain's grip however
before he can land a fatal blow they are
interrupted by Falling debris Conan then
takes Tamara and tries to escape the
cave as they make their way to a wooden
bridge she accidentally slips and falls
through a hole Conan immediately grabs
her by her chain and starts pulling her
up at the same time kalar catches up and
approaches Conan who has both of his
hands occupied he then resumes the
ritual and begins summoning his dead
wife as a result of this the spirit of
the old witch possesses Tamara's body
and she begs Conan to Let Her Go however
the ladder isn't ready to give up on her
at any cost when Kar comes closer Conan
uses his sword to cut off a part of the
bridge causing the evil guy to fall to
his death this interrupts the ritual
returning Tamara back to her normal
state after this Conan uses the last of
his energy to pull her up and the pair
manages to escape the cave moments
before it collapses in the aftermath
Conan drops Tamara at her birthplace and
departs assuring her that they'll meet
again he then returns to his destroyed
Village to show his father's grave that
he's finally become worthy of this sword
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching